you talk about knowledge you talk about
wisdom
what what uh kind of wisdom do you draw
from kung fu movies the you know what
the martial art itself and the movies
this endless wisdom to be drawn and i
draw it
you know
i draw it in a way you know that i could
decipher it in my own life
so
for instance
in the movie master killer
uh
he basically
when he does kung fu he does a really a
style called the hangar technique
and the director of the movie
is actually a hangar expert
who has a lineage
that traces all the way back to shaolin
temple and this director always wanted
to
keep his
movies pure and the brain on god to the
world it's like he wanted to show the
world
this lineage in fact you just said
master of the flying guillotine is
quentin's favorite movie and we
mentioned in 36 champions it's my
favorite movie but
the action director of master flying
guillotine is the director of 36
chambers of charlotte yeah and some of
the things that's happening
in
mass of the fl of the flying guillotine
is really the infant stage of what this
action director is going to learn and
then use later on in his movies
so that's the beauty of it it's almost
like
you know
quentin is seeing him
in his generation so queen might have
been the same age i was watching that
movie and then when he becomes a
director i'm at quentin's age and now
i'm seeing his work so some symbionic
relationship there
and i'll end this question by saying
hungar deals with the five animal
technique
the tiger the crane
right the leopard
the snake uh and the dragon those are
the five that's the five patterns some
people go seven so i'll go twelve but
let's just stick to the five pattern
fists
how do
a man
emulate a tiger
and you see a tiger's fist
he curls before he spawns on you
how does a man emulate
a snake
it doesn't have to be only in the
kung-fu move
it's in the ideology
of the snake
it's in the
the the agility of the crane
at any moment
sometimes punching a person
is not going to work
as they were saying leopard fist or
tiger paw
so sometimes you might have to poke them
in the eye with the crane's beak
so having your mind able to adapt the
instinct
of the animal when you are being
attacked
or when you are being the aggressor
that's something that you don't need a
form for that's the mentality so kung fu
like i said it informs me endlessly
because at first i was trying to learn
all the uh home
like i can't really hit you with that
and really hurt you unless i've been
banging my hand a thousand times on some
bricks and made it so callous or muscles
are so strong but the idea
that if me and you was to get into a
fight and i'm going to tiger up on you
and take that instinct and prance when
i'm a prince
or
slop
fly away like the stalk
you know i mean like yo
it's this that's the mentality it's much
more than the technical moves it's
it's much deeper yeah
yeah it's interesting i mean when i see
the kung fu movies because i'm uh i love
martial arts all martial arts and
competitive ones too like the actual
competitions and so on it just seems
like kung fu movies
go much deeper than just like the
techniques yeah they start i mean if you
see it right
even i watched the great mma fight
recently and uh
just interesting
because he was on top of the god
you know
and the way he got from under him
you know
it had to be
you know his spirit got from under
some like mixture of crane and uh
whatever snake
ill slippery ill technique yeah no i
love that when people are become artists
in the cage or they that's much bigger
than just like winning much bigger than
particular techniques it's just art
especially at the highest level
competition where millions of people are
watching
which is pressure within itself yes yes
that's
art under pressure is even more
beautiful art you know you look at some
of these fights and you wonder like why
somebody wins and lose
and sometimes the less talented guy
could win
because he could deal with the pressure
or the other guy he could have beat him
they were somewhere else but not in this
arena
you